gang New Year's Day we got a special
treat for you oh baby yeah we're gonna
be coming to you live from Aunt Cody's
house shaking off those hangovers
together yeah I won't be able to cut
anything during this we're going
out we're doing it live let's go oh it's
gonna be fantastic we've got a lot of
cool stuff planned we're gonna have some
guests coming by we're gonna be a little
hair to dog boys are going to be boozing
get rid of The Hangover Blues we got
Patty and Denise making appearance which
I haven't told her about yet
guys it's all going down at uhmoment.com
we're gonna be live streaming uh Sunday
January 1st at 8pm Eastern sign up now
yeah do it welcome to another exciting
edition of are you garbage the show
where you find out if your favorite
comedians are classy individuals or
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit down with your favorite comedians
and we find that the group to be classy
yeah those are just a big old piece of
trash I'm your host Dave trolley coming
at you on a beautiful day we're down
here at antuti's basement she just
handed me her Christmas wish list okay a
tripod and a ring light all right fair
enough asking for trouble Mike co-host
is coming at you from right next to me I
kind of got it halfway he is the CEO of
are you garbage he is an international
businessman he's my best pal in the
whole wide world and that's all I want
for Christmas give it up for KJ Kevin
James Ryan Hey gang what's up thanks for
tuning in as always make sure you rate
view subscribe on iTunes full video of
album YouTube as you know those numbers
are true to roof cooking over 100k over
there oh and obviously the greatest
goddamn website of all time
www.patreon.com are you garbage talk
about a [ __ ] life-changing website
that is yikes [ __ ] Google kick rocks
and then obviously we just announced uh
our new York City Show tickets are on
let's go it's our on sale now for the
Gramercy [ __ ] theater get those
tickets Army garbage let's sell it the
[ __ ] out yeah come see us gang and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer extraordinaire the magic man
makes us all look good works the ones
and twos crosses the D's and dots the
eyes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin Toby
McMullen everybody what's up dudes
what's up T-Bone it's Christmas time in
New York baby let's do it I saw Santa
get stabbed on the G train and that
happens what'll happen enough of that
talk we have guests here God damn it
Jesus Christ gang we could be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time he has a
very funny stand-up comedian actor and
writer and podcaster and you've seen him
in but not limited to we got Superior
Donuts we got drunk history Alone
Together Goat Face corporate a moral
compass United States of Al wrote 14
episodes no big deal it's a writer you
also got Seth Meyers you got at midnight
you got last call with Carson Daly
tigerbelly UTF Joe Rogan Conan he has an
amazing special from 2017 called There's
No Business Like Show Business and he
also has an absolutely fantastic brand
new special out right now called hat
trick filmed at the world famous comedy
store and he has an amazing podcast
called faheem Anwar dance hour ladies
and gentlemen Fahim Anwar oh my God
thank you look at that he's a good
looking kid I'm all right
you're disgusting you know it makes me
feel like I've done stuff when you read
because I feel like [ __ ] most of the
time and maybe then you like read those
things I'm like oh yeah I've done I've
worked kid's a worker man 14 episodes
yeah I like the deep cut of like last
call with Carson Daly shout out to CD
all right I just I'm just like lucky
enough I don't have that as my credit
still when I hit the stage oh yeah I was
gonna use that last just expired credits
dude
yeah
TV shows that are no longer on the air
it was like laughs on Fox got them
comedy live Comics Unleashed oh yeah if
I got on it it got canceled very soon a
couple episodes of cops that's all you
got yeah everybody congratulations on
the special oh thanks dude thanks man
absolutely fantastic you're bringing the
Pod back you said yeah bring it back
Hiatus when I had the writing job time
was kind of limited but yeah gonna bring
it back nice yeah give us a scoop what's
the uh what's the backstory give us the
origin story here the human origin story
yeah okay let's see grew up in Seattle
okay people think East Coast people
think I'm from New York but I've never
do have a little bit of New York what is
that I don't know I don't know a little
bit of a tube the hair whoa this is blow
dried though so that's not I gotta fake
it get the hell out of here yeah I saw
him in the back yeah I don't wake up
like that I wish I did trust me you
don't want to wake up like that believe
me my friend yeah you're doing all right
yeah so yeah I grew up in Seattle and
then Jail's beautiful we were just there
is the city proper no the birds The
Burbs The Burbs so first Linwood and
then mukultio and then Woodenville turn
Woodenville so that's where I went to
high school what'd the folks do dad
engineering
I knew it was gonna be a sharp kid I
knew this was coming in good lineage
your dad was an engineer at Boeing
engineer Boeing what do you work on
commercial commercial really yeah yeah
okay 737 and triple seven you might have
done seven four seven two yeah it's like
just like forever that's the coal mine
like before Tech came in it was all
about Everett and and Boeing and playing
like everyone worked at Boeing sure they
still do it's huge but right now there's
Amazon now there's you know okay he's
working on air he's working on aircraft
he's getting what are we doing here he's
into cubicle I was saying like he's
getting his hands get his hands down
he's getting his hands dirty on
calculators
wait he's not flying what's going on
here so he worked where'd he go to
school he went to two he went to North
Dakota State and then he also went to
Minnesota okay yeah not bad engineer
what'd your mom do nursing first and
then she did that for a long time and
then she pivoted into like hair so she
does hair now okay yeah all right she
worked in a salon and she'd do it in the
house uh at a salon okay has a station
at a salon nice yeah how long has she
had that maybe like 10 years now or like
eight eight ten years was she ever
cutting hair in the house before all the
time even before she was doing that like
trying to Pivot she would cut my
brother's hair and my hair and my dad's
hair just to save money where at in the
house was that happening we do the
bathroom I'd always have to get the
chair from my brother's room
floor I've done it yeah I take back
everything I say and then like when she
was new to it she would like it was a
haircut that would take two hours no
that's never good wait so too fast or
too slow is bad for you yeah you need
the meaty part of the curve she was in
nursing never did any hair stuff before
at all but this is just an immigrant
thing like I'm not gonna pay a
professional to cut hair I have scissors
you have hair like so she didn't even
she didn't start cutting your guys hair
as kids because someday she wanted to be
in the business she was just doing it at
a necessity kind of just to save money
and at some point she's like you know
what I like this I want to juice I never
thought about it that way that maybe we
were just a gateway to her dream yeah
finally clicked in yeah I just thought
that it was a financial thing like we
don't want to pay money for you to go to
someone let me just cut your hair how
bad were the haircuts from jumping they
were they weren't terrible you know but
she would always take pride in it like
every time I'd come home from school she
would be like did people what did they
say yeah
she would think that I'm trending like
like all the girls yeah have you seen
his new haircut it's [ __ ] awesome who
cut his mom his mom
okay that's pretty good do your parents
still live in the same house that you
grew up in no this is like third third
or fourth okay
um what was the name of that street that
you grew up on like the bulk of my
childhood I would say Serene way hello
that one got the peanut gallery
sounds very nice how much was your mom
charging you for those haircuts
apartment condo townhouse what are we
talking it was a house okay multiple
rooms I had my room I had a room my
brother had a room my parents had a room
how far apart are you and your brother
three and a half years okay yeah older
or younger older you're younger younger
yeah all right that's good not bad was
there a garage at that house there was
two garages what did you just say what
like a two-door garage a two weight
there was two there was one garage or
two garages like when you look at the
garage
but one girl okay I got you yeah what
were you parking in there what was the
old man whipping around then oh [ __ ]
what did he have okay we there was
always a fan okay there's always a Dodge
Caravan
that is I guess that's like an
affordable reliable it's like a staple
some family here or were they born your
parents born no Afghanistan parents are
both from Afghanistan they drove the
Dodge Caravan
[Laughter]
yeah okay so that and then maybe like a
Toyota Corolla that was kind of a staple
a van and a Toyota Corolla they're too
very that is I think that is a very
immigrant mentality you sort of like
cutting the hair it's like they're very
practical affordable reliable things oh
yeah yeah yeah yeah two-car garage
though did you where would you could you
fit two cars in it or was it filled with
[ __ ] no you could fit two yeah was there
a refrigerator in that garage there was
what was in there uh like frozen meats
it's sort of like my mom's just storing
stuff for gosh you know I mean like long
term sure you're not going in and out a
bunch but there's like sauces in there
maybe that they're frozen sure yeah yeah
any sodas
uh yeah there'd be like a case of Coke
okay you know so if you want you would
like go to the garage it counts as a
garage fridge I got you I got you
because my car I grew up with a Korean
my Korean buddy they had a fridge in the
garage but it was mostly Korean food but
then they also had like you know the
Americanized ice pops and sodas and [ __ ]
like that yeah yeah yeah it was more
it's mostly my mom's fridge like we
didn't really have [ __ ] in there we just
had in the regular fridge gotcha or the
snack situations good snacks or were you
jealous of the others oh my god dude I
would go to my white friend's house and
I it was like Willy Wonka's chocolate
factory it's like being in a supermarket
like when I moved to Woodinville my next
door neighbor across the street uh David
Bradley like we would go to his whitest
guy in the world
always cooking there the first time I
opened up he's like yeah grab something
from the pantry it was like a real I
could walk into it yeah they were big
that was they were big in the 90s all my
life after you open up a door closet
yeah it's like a closet yeah his was
there's like lights in there you could
enter and they had its own light switch
that was some balling-ass [ __ ] yeah if
your pantry had a light switch it
smelled like candy it was like a
convenience store in there I've been in
I've been in [ __ ] smaller casting a
couple of lottery picks yeah there was a
Korean guy in there telling me you just
have to hurry up as well but they hired
him he'll be on payroll so they think
you're stealing like at my house we only
had Coke he had Dr Pepper he had like
cream sodas you know the bottle ones are
even more expensive different types
that's crazy the Only Rule he had was
when you take one uh or if you take
something from the fridge put it back
like you you know replenish it sure like
that's easy enough that's pretty good
take a soda leave a soda were you were
they were they pretty strict with the
snacks or could you have my parents yeah
she would like okay lay it out for him
my mom used to get uh like Chips Ahoy
cookies for us all right pretty good and
now that I'm older that's like an
economy cookie they're pretty [ __ ]
good no but you get so many that it's an
immigrant thing again like compared to
what are we talking about though look
nowadays I would get a Tates cookie or
you know like hey it's who's getting
dated that's crazy taste is cutting hair
in the kitchen what are you crazy who's
got Tates money hates are great yes but
you're not as you're not stuck in the
house with Tates for children
how many come into Chips Ahoy how many I
probably about 25 30. you get a couple
rows uh maybe I call it 30. yeah let's
say it works a lot so I think I used to
put down a sleeve a day oh yeah she
would hide them she would put them
um in the dishwasher what and then they
would taste like dishwasher but I would
still eat them wait yeah that's all you
got why would she put them in the
dishwasher because you thought I
wouldn't look in there but I I would
or she would put them on top of the kid
with a bad haircut looking around
dumbass won't find him in here oh man I
used to love them when you would find
the hiding spot
there would always there'd always be a
moment of like yeah you thought you were
gonna get me didn't you you didn't think
I'd crawl up on top of the refrigerator
and look in the cabinet up there what am
I a [ __ ] idiot I got eight hours
you're at work all day tearing this
place apart like I'm the feds would you
think that she wouldn't find out like
even though half of them are gone yeah
yeah I don't know I didn't oh you put
them up there maybe the dishwasher ain't
them I don't know all right that's
pretty good what was the pool situation
pool no pool no pool backyard
yeah there's a backyard who's cutting
the grass over there my dad of course
dad would cut it push mower riding mower
uh gasoline like push okay do it every
Saturday Sunday whatever yeah yeah my
dad's all about kept it tight huh he did
build a basketball court but like a
Yankee basketball court for us in the
backyard or in the drive back yeah it's
me my uh backyard okay so we like poured
[ __ ] blacktop he kind of so he hired
this company or some guy to like pour
cement and there was these two by fours
that like kind of cut the court just for
structure or whatever sure and this
cement well at the frame the frame the
frame yeah so the guy did a beautiful
job so smooth so level and then my dad
couldn't just leave it alone he's like I
can fix it so he took out like two
little hand smoothers and then it just
got worse and worse oh yeah he kept on
trying to smooth it out and then just
for years we had a lumpy court and we
would trip on the the two by four
because my family tries to do everything
themselves well he should have just he
just should have left it the guy did a
great job but he couldn't just leave
well enough alone were you guys really
into basketball why did he do this yeah
because we left basketball I think he
was doing us it was a nice like fatherly
solid sure for the kids were you a good
basketball player I was good until
everyone else grew sure I was amazing I
was like LeBron I was like really good I
was fast I could shoot but then I stayed
short for so long oh man I hated those
kids that killed him like fourth and
fifth grade
I remember trying out for the basketball
team and like I wanted it in the worst
way
and then they would they
did you guys ever get cut from Sports
yeah yeah how do they do it did they
just put a list up
I think yeah okay this was [ __ ] up the
way I got written off the list
no he would say I want to bring you in
like he's gonna bring all the kids in
one by one and let you know whether
you're on the team or not and give you
some input what is this like little
league basketball no this is like Middle
School oh I'm in like sixth grade or
something okay no I've never been cut
from a school team oh really yeah damn
no all right well I did so I'm trying
out for a week or two oh that's not a
big technically that's clear with
everybody
there's only a little league everybody
so I mean I would prefer just a list and
be like okay my name's not on there I'll
just sulk and go home he did it like
Moneyball yeah yeah
so I'm trading you for soda money
gave me the name and number of the coach
from another school
Hillcrest now enjoy it
yeah so then I had to get called into
this guy's office and he's like have a
seat and he's telling me everything that
I'm bad at and I'm I'm just like oh yeah
just trying to hold in tears yeah what
the [ __ ] yeah I'll work on that you're
not the Lakers dude Jesus Christ just
let me go home yeah
that's all right damn all right yikes
that's pretty bad oh my basketball court
is wild because you have a basketball
court at your house but it's lumpy maybe
that's why I got cut yeah
this is bumpier I would run circles
around you guys whatever coach your
court stinks it's not even a hump in the
middle
how do you do bouncers uh what was the
name of the mall
Alderwood Mall Alderwood Mall movie
theater in there yeah huh yeah what was
the two main department stores do you
remember
uh I don't know when I was a kid we
would hit Zoomies a lot shout out to
zoomy zoomy are they still around yeah I
bought a pair of shoes there not too
long ago and Spencer's Spencer's was
like early porno for kids a couple of
erotic uh greeting cards yeah
okay sperm candle oh my God I shouldn't
be seeing this that's pretty good I
don't hate it what um what was the high
school mascot
uh Falcon did you play in high school I
played uh tennis I played Titanic yeah
okay are you good at that doubles I
don't think I was good enough to be
singles doubles they have doubles tennis
in high school yeah that just seems like
I played I played women so I wasn't
I was [ __ ] spiking it on these yeah
they demoted me from doubles to women's
[Laughter]
that's pretty good uh What was your what
was your first car
my first car you know I wanted to be
like my brother because my brother was
all about cars he got a 91 or 9 a
90-something Honda Civic hatchback with
tinted windows alloy wheels uh like two
Kicker 12 Subs in the back of the subs
in the back probably a nice head unit in
there too yeah yeah remember when like
dolphins on the LCD was such a stunt so
he was living on my life yeah like
detachable yeah put it in the case so he
had I was like oh I want that I can't
wait till I'm old enough to do that but
then I just realized I don't care to
like go through it wasn't even
Craigslist newspaper when's he rocking
this about what age would you say
uh no yeah when you get your license
sixteen sixteen yeah it was maybe 17. 16
17 and what did he do he worked to save
up and get all this yeah he would work
at Safeway like yeah and then paper out
before that to hook the car up right so
my dad had a deal like you we pay half
he pays the other half that's good dad I
like that too keeps you working or else
you get some tight [ __ ] out of it yeah
kids don't really do that [ __ ] now do
they like nobody really hooks the car up
well they're making millions off Tick
Tock so they don't need their dad they
have a drive they just dance yeah but
I'm just saying like I never see no
they're still dirt bags that are putting
you know after effects yeah like yeah
after effects uh or whatever it's called
yeah after market sure yeah so then I
just uh I got out of that phase then my
dad just bought a car he bought this
like shitty 89 Toyota Corolla a
champagne Toyota Corolla that call they
were all that champion yeah and every
single one of them was crazy and then it
all smelled the same too yeah and then
he goes like do you want it just give me
like 4 000 I go yeah okay it was just
easy I liked how easy it was and I would
have a car so I I you know I didn't need
the tinted windows and all that wait he
charged you four grand for it half of it
whatever maybe it wasn't maybe it was
like two
it was cheap how old are you at this
point I think I got my license I was
like 16 16 or 17. you had two G's on you
yeah man really where were you working I
would do okay first job was paper route
okay how old are we talking
12 or 13. okay yeah it was called the
Enterprise newspaper and I would deliver
that around the like around Serene Lake
that's the neighborhood that I live so I
would do that and then the job after
that when we moved to Woodinville I
worked at Cottage Lake Safeway okay
I was a bagger myself yeah it's like
Tetris right oh I lie still doing it at
self-checkout I get all it gets me hard
you gotta get one last Rodeo
you're doing other people buy apron yeah
no you could do this for a living you're
like I did I used to I'll handle that
darling I just do it for fun now eggs on
top what are you crazy bread on bottom
change the game exit about it I loved it
man it's an OCD thing I worked there
when I was because they would they would
hire you when you were young yeah 15 and
a half okay the barrier of Entry so
you're working started working when you
were a kid saved up your money yeah and
then Nikes when I was five I would make
those no I'm just kidding
my dad's like I'm sending you to China
you need to learn dental plan wasn't
great but it was all right yeah gang
today's episode is sponsored by by
PayPal honey sweet as honey the easy way
to save When shopping on your phone or
your computer we all love shopping
online that's no secret we don't nobody
wants to wait in the store anymore what
happens to all of us we do our little
shopping yeah we get to the end get to
the checkout do you got a promo code I
got nothing never have a promo well I'm
paying full price like a goddamn
[ __ ] I know but gang thanks to Honey
searching for coupon codes is going to
be a thing of the pack yeah guys it is
fantastic as you know I I dabble in the
online shopping industry he's Frugal
this one no no no no I'm bad with money
I think it is but not anymore with honey
babies that day I was buying a nice pair
of kicks I'm gonna be kick guy Kippy
kibby's kicks and uh you get there and
it's like do you have a promo code and
you panic and you just you go to the
depth of the internet you Google you
don't want to see what Google takes you
when you look for a promo code yikes ah
but honey takes care of that Kroger yeah
and scours the internet I saved about 20
beans on my shoes really baby I love
honey and you will too I'll never go
shopping without it you can save even
more when you ask honey to keep track of
price drops on your holiday shopping
list if the price drops on any any item
on your list you'll instantly get an
alert and let you know if you don't
already have honey you can be straight
up missing out by getting it you're
doing yourself a solid and supporting
the podcast we never recommend anything
we don't use I use honey every [ __ ]
day so go get honey for free at
joinhoney.com garbage that's
joinhoney.com garbage do it okay let's
talk about that true classic oh baby I'm
wearing one right now shout out to the
true Classic this is the most
comfortable the best fitting t-shirt
you're ever gonna own I can tell you
that right now and yeah I squeeze into
them all right I heard you talking [ __ ]
they come big they're fantastic they're
great I love them yeah listen gang enjoy
your milk and cookies this holiday
season it does not matter you got true
Classics back in the up fits all in the
right place his sleeves are a little
shorter good around the belly top top
quality product I'm telling you yeah if
you're a heavy bike boy like us I'm
telling you you need a little room
around a waist tighten the arms you feel
like an old Varsity athlete I tell you
back to my football days I got Polo's
workout boxers uh uh keep the boys
feeling nice and comfortable true
classic has something for everybody on
the list and they even got big boy
options like we said right now you get
25 off trueclassic.com garbage free
shipping included on purchases over a
hundred bucks a 25 off at
trueclassics.com garbage Santa won't be
the only one slaying thanks to True
Classics I'm gonna have sex with my wife
uh what about
um the vacations as a kid where would
you go what would you guys do we would
do Frugal kind of affordable local
Vacations so we would go to Canada a lot
we would go to this place called
Penticton Penticton or pentuckton there
and then Kelowna there was a place in
Canada called Kelowna my dad would
always say like it's the Hawaii of
Canada was it a beat it was a beach yeah
there was a beach yeah it was nice it's
fun it's fine yeah from Hawaii the
Hawaii of Canada saying a lot probably
freezing now it was it was fine it was
yeah we were just like February yeah
this is a bunch of mounties eating spam
it was like in our jackass just freezing
and he's like it's the Hawaii okay
who babysat you when you were a kid do
you have any babies was there any of
their family around uh like cousins and
stuff and aunts so yeah but where did
your parents come over like late 70s
they came over in the late 70s and did
they have family that was already over
here no like uh my yeah my dad had some
like they were starting to come over
around the same time there wasn't like a
bunch of people here so the trickle was
happening any tight family like did you
have any cousins like first cousins or
second cousins growing up yeah yeah
there was my cousin Mustafa and nilo
they were they're gonna make a few Towns
over maybe all right 30 minute car ride
that's not bad you see them a lot yeah
maybe like twice twice a month that's
good so who would watch you as a kid who
would be your babysitter probably I mean
my brother when he got old enough I
don't recall having babysitters really
like somebody from outside coming in
yeah not really okay yeah that's pretty
good how would you get to school bus
Walk Drive so like Elementary School I
would walk we were close enough to
Serene Lake Elementary where I would I
would walk would everybody in the
neighborhood walk yeah if you lived
around where we did you could walk it
was there always a sidewalk are we ever
actually on the road
uh we were on the road for like half of
it
stepping over time we're getting closer
all right yeah we're cracking this thing
wide open I used to play bass all right
electric two oh yeah yeah yeah one right
behind you damn are you still good no he
bought it for me for a Christmas
it hasn't left the studio again this
year yeah would you make me an offer
yeah how much he'll pay half
[Laughter]
are you still good I was never good yeah
me too I was never solid I would look up
tabs you know like how to say Long View
yeah do you still own a base
it's still at my parents house still at
your parents house yeah amp Gibson okay
yeah no instruments in the house that
you live in now the apartment you live
in now no no guitars on the wall or
anything like that no I would just be
like a poser I'd be faking it yeah okay
okay who was the name of your uh
pediatrician
oh man oh doctor Dr Gellen sounds pretty
respectable yeah was that office in his
home no my mom used to work for him okay
there you go to the family oh hookup oh
yeah he used to have a dog he had like a
dog that he would yeah it was just like
a company with him this is before
bringing your dog was cool
yeah yeah and the office wasn't in his
house it was not it was a professional
Center Professional Center and it was a
dog running around yeah with a bandana
huh that don't help you out all right
that was funny because I went into this
coffee shop and it was a dog friendly
coffee shop which I thought was sweet I
love doggies but the lady that was
working there she'd come around and
[ __ ] be petting the dog and like
[ __ ] touching its mouth yeah they
gotta wash their hands every time that
she went back there she's raw dogging my
latte like what the hell lady if I want
dog slobber I'll get kisses like a
gentleman
um would you buy your school lunch or
would you take a lunch my mom would pack
a lunch I would have the same sandwich
for years and years it's uh like a
turkey maybe turkey cheese lettuce on it
it was a respectable school lunches all
right
Panasonic thrown in there no Capri Sun
come on like soda that cuts into your
free Sun family who wasn't yeah you guys
are younger Capri Sun was super
expensive when I was
so what was the drink of choice then the
drink of choice was that was the high
seas they were the ones that were cheap
when they whenever
in the 80s
it's [ __ ] space the Space Age stuff
they got it for me interesting but she
would go to Costco so I'm sure she got a
great deal on it but what the bougie uh
fruit juice for us growing up was a
squeeze it if you had a squeeze there
wasn't enough for them man
they came in those six packs were barely
a pack dude those were like cigarettes
in jail if you had to squeeze it man
that blue squeezer they were like syrup
they were so concentrated just beautiful
packaging yeah
you felt like you were a bartender okay
there you go crack it I got so good I
could break up the edge of a table
I think we got a lighter yeah yeah all
right okay remember squeezes yeah I
forgot about that [ __ ] any other snacks
in in the lunch with you the sandwich
yeah a fruit snack uh Fruit Roll-Up
yes so it's fruit rolled for a bit and
then gushers was nice I really that was
kind of you know that's pretty guys are
doing well yeah you're doing all right
fruit roll-ups
everybody the foot sucked
no you were just sleeping by the foot
was great you just had to [ __ ] take
it all out and roll it up and put it in
your mouth at once
just saying sure all your Foods by the
way I feel I get three feet of beef
um
did you take the SATs yeah what'd you
get you seem like a bright young I swear
to God I don't remember no no no I swear
to God but here's the thing it didn't
matter for me because I did this program
called Running start where you could
take half Community College classes
everything's safe with this guy the
death it's with the Community College my
dad don't have to test for me I swear to
God yes I gotta give them two grand but
still so it didn't matter what I got on
it because I was already in college
classes or whatever my path was going to
be transferring from Community College
to a four-year University and then your
SAT scores don't matter when you
transfer right so I was doing my senior
year of college or uh High School I was
doing half Community College courses in
half high school so I was driving off
campus really you were hanging out at a
community college in high school yeah it
was only out front smoking cigarettes on
the top of his car squeeze it and I was
just like wow what's up lady wait so you
hold on that's pretty [ __ ] trashy I
like this yeah it's to get ahead I know
but here's the thing though that he's a
child he's not 18 he's hanging out a
[ __ ] Community College in the 90s
he was definitely offered cigarettes
early 2000s
quite a picture of a kid in a diaper at
a community college with criminals
that's not the case he was a senior in
high school but you were you were under
18 correct yeah and you were driving
yourself to a community college and
walking around those Halls and said
what's under 18 with those degenerates
in there this is true I was I was in
community college for like a week I was
trying to pray
these kids
I know what goes on there I was on the
other end of it it's a shifting
situation you're lucky
it was nice because they just assume
you're a good kid which I mostly am but
like they just trust you're going to
community college but I could just [ __ ]
off because I'm going off campus yeah so
it's great you have this freedom to be
independent and adults yeah yeah it's
mature any trouble as a kid
uh nothing major rob a bank or anything
I've never been arrested
but one time I mean you say am I good
kid or not just one time I had this
weird outlier I don't know why I did
this kill a guy
I don't know what came over man I just
saw red and then the police were there
we're in my backyard my parents house
and they had this moat of like rocks
just for like decorative rocks and then
me and him just started throwing rocks
through the neighbor's window you and
your brother no just a friend a
neighborhood friend how old were you
maybe like 11 11 or 12. and our goal was
just to get all the glass out of the
window like it was a game was somebody
living there yeah
well someone could have been taking a
[ __ ]
maybe yeah I don't know to this day I
don't know why I did it so we just we
just kept on throwing rocks through the
window trying to clear all the glass
make it super clean and then I got in
trouble is anybody home
had no but they found out obviously
because one rock would scare the [ __ ]
out of you if another one comes in
you're like oh something's going on
right on we're under attack yeah no [ __ ]
so I mean we had to pay for the window
but that's the only time I can think of
something doing that's pretty I mean do
you get grounded or anything for that
I think I just yelled at we didn't get
grounded we just got yelled at really
hard by your who mom or dad did you know
Dad Dad isn't Superstar at that but then
Mom if it's big enough sure but she's
more the loving type but my dad's a
disciplinarian when the mom yells it was
always scarier because you weren't
expecting a little bit yeah and she had
the sandal or like you know it was big
with the sandal yeah yeah I'll get hit
with a slipper sometimes sure everybody
takes a slipper every once in a while
what are you gonna do hmm all right
right you guys ever lived near a quarry
or a cemetery
no okay that's the weird thing about I
was in Philly doing shows and Shout out
yeah shout out to it walking around
there's just there's always plots just a
square of all these dead stones yeah
yeah old school ones yeah you can't even
it's smooth you can't even see the
engraving it's you're so removed from it
it's almost like a history piece even
though there's like bones under there
yeah
like no one is crying you know like no
one's giving flowers and crying we're so
far removed oh yeah yeah it was just
interesting to have a latte yeah
it'd be nice if someone did though right
somebody does there's there's there
might be a couple different channels or
a couple different pages of nice people
that go around and they get old Graves
like that and they power wash them
cutting them up yeah that's pretty cool
do they re-engrave it because it's
smooth a little bit Yeah they hook it up
they make it nice it's called pimp my
headstone what's up I'm next to the Z
exhibit I get him back we're doing a
spin-off I always think that was the
worst thing exhibit did career-wise like
he's a gangster rapper but I just heard
it made him like a bajillion dollars
yeah I always thought the same thing I
don't know Tebow can you get a isn't he
sad though a part of him that like I'm
sure he would still love to be on that
music path but when you had it though
what he was with Dre and he was plugged
in but and then you're pimping 16 year
old girls cars with popcorn machines
like hooked them up though yeah but it's
a great branding Wise It's very sure you
shouldn't do that he just came out I
just saw an interview with him about
this because I thought the same thing
and I think he either made like zero
dollars or like a bajillion it was one
of the other half a mill an episode or
total that's not worth
that's not worth it
real big shot huh yeah he can't even
pimp his own ride at that kind of money
now there's five just is 500 Grand a
bajillion dollars I said or nothing so
it was closer or nothing back then it
was a bajillion dollars that's true yeah
but he wasn't that great of a rapper
he was on track dude if you're part of
the Dre Camp Chronic 2001 came out he's
all over that yeah but he had crime
you're gonna get one of us gripped up at
Carbones what are you doing over here
exhibit we love you buddy I'm a big fan
of starting beefs on the street just
calling it like I say you know what I
mean
rap guy myself
um how many Fast and Furious movies have
you seen in the theater maybe two or
three me and my brother we saw this is
the last one we saw we came out of the
theater and we were like laughing
hysterically like it was a comedy to us
how crazy it is yes because once they
stopped at a certain point they stopped
obeying the laws of physics building to
building like their cars are in space
they're going from like Mars to the Moon
just there's no more story lines with
traditional physics that they're [ __ ]
going oh it's the one where someone's
hard drive is on like the 500th floor of
this like Dubai Penthouse or whatever
and they [ __ ] like they drink a car
yeah in the elevator they got the car in
the elevator or something something
absurd yeah and that's where I was like
this is just a comedy okay fast and
furious seven movie [ __ ] rules hmm
you saw seven of them no no I haven't
seen no how many are they up to now I
think nine Jesus I think I've seen the
first two and then I checked out
yeah is Luda still in him now there's a
rapper
yo he's had longevity man of course
shout out to Chris Bridges I think that
was his name uh what about going to eat
is at gout to eat as a family what would
that look like did that happen what was
the story there okay yeah the treat for
us we would go to Godfather's Pizza okay
was that National or was that just local
that sounds like it's regional I've seen
a couple of them floaters there would be
this old guy with like a hat and he
would say like do it like that those are
the commercials like Godfather's pizza's
like oh do it I like hey I'm listening
yeah that's all right I literally want
to go just from that impression their
tagline is Godfather's Pizza a pizza you
can't refuse
yeah set us up table for two are they
still around or is it done oh yeah oh
[ __ ] they're still banging so okay we
would go there every Friday or ever
sometimes on a Friday okay we were so
jacked to go there that's great and my
dad bought this there was a special
economy soda jug where if you bought it
once oh boy you get the three refills so
every time we would have to like load up
the jug when we went to Godfather's
Pizza and then one time we were like
almost there and he's like where's The
Jug
we didn't have the jug so we turned
around and we went back home to get the
jug yeah back to Godfather's Pizza
because they're not gonna get one over
my dad no yeah all right I'm not buying
a second jug for these animals yeah yeah
that's pretty good you guys ever cook
out in public ever use like the the
public grills something like a park or
anything no it's pretty good are you a
Bagel Bites or pizza roll kind of guy
and or family neither my mom would buy
party pizza Totino's party which I loved
when I was a kid and then it's funny you
get older and you like bro you walk by
the aisle and you see what it's priced
at mm-hmm and it's like you 48 seconds
or so yeah it's crazy yeah
um it's good though it's good so we're
having that piece of knowledge knowing
it's not like premium Pizza sure
retroactively makes me like less even
though when I was a kid I was like this
is the best thing yeah party pizza
um what uh if you're gonna do a frozen
pizza now what do you do
I can do a DiGiorno I can do okay
respected DiGiorno a Red Baron some but
this the sauce is a little like spice
the Red Baron sauce is a little Kelly I
gotta yeah I gotta be in the mood for a
record
[Music]
I can do an Amy's but that's aiming it's
priced too high yeah Amy's is crazy it
feels I don't go to The Godfather she
wants nine bucks for a can of soup what
are you doing and they're small pizzas
too yeah yeah DiGiorno is your best dude
you pick up a DiGiorno it's about 13
pounds yeah every time I'm walking it
feels like a sewer cap I'm like dude
this is so Frozen crusting nothing I'm
trying to think I was in this like small
right doll Studio One time I couldn't
like it wasn't very big so I would have
to cut a frozen Digiorno into two pieces
and then re-wrap it sure and wrap and
put two halves like I'm chopping up a
body
a lot of people have to we were somebody
just wrote in about having to do that of
like chopping up the frozen pizza which
I never had to do I need a bone saw like
it's hard to cut it's funny I've heard
people that did that intentionally
because they didn't want to they didn't
want to cook the whole thing they wanted
that's smart instead of buying personal
because they sell those Red Baron
persons yeah but it's probably more cost
effective to buy a big one and chop it
up kids how about Rex man oh baby shout
out to him new kid in the market they're
doing all the hard work if you catch my
trip I
shout out to all you limp noodles out
there gang or if you're just looking for
an extra extra pep in your step I need
it I'll tell you that right now I'm
getting older I need a little I need I
need to juice a little bit you know what
I mean yeah call me the Burger King I'm
juicing baby yeah I don't know what to
tell you gang do yourself a favor get
over to Rex Med all right makes getting
generic branded Viagra or say Alice easy
so you can get rock [ __ ] hot
something you can hang from baby
guys what are we talking about here
everybody knows listen it's got you
gotta have it on you Dude Sweet when
you're ready when it's game time I keep
about two Tree in my pocket at all times
chewing one now uh Rex man has made the
whole process simple it's just a few
clicks of a button talk to a medical
professional create a personalized plan
and get the products discreetly shipped
to yours straight to your door within
two days nothing labeled boner Bells
Viagra can cost around 90 a pill Rex
meds generic Viagra is just as effective
as low as two bucks a pill move them out
the door more than just ED medication
they have sexual health hair growth pain
relief sleep aid the whole nine yards
man talk about the plug let's go I know
shout out to Rex man guys if you act now
take advantage of their best deal yet by
heading to rexmed.com garbage our
exclusive deal will save up to 90 off
where you'll only be paying two dollars
per dosage starter packs of generic
Viagra or Cialis are now available for
our listeners to get started that's
rexmed.com garbage for up to 90 off give
the gift of pleasure this holiday season
with Rex man more like sex man am I yeah
Rex man get hard today KIPP it's
manscaped baby you mean the best in the
GD Biz manscaped you smell that
smells like clean balls right there I'll
tell you that gang you keep them trimmed
keep them on your mustache earlier
and I can't smell anything
I've had new car smell they're using
over there yeah they got shampoos body
wash Upstairs Downstairs deodorant gels
exfoliants cover absolutely everything
you need to keep clean uh they got the
shears 2.0 their full kit for Nail Care
with scissors Clippers tweezers and a
file that's great to go on and go baby
shout out to manscape plus they got that
lawnmower 4.0 the electric razor
Advanced Skin safe technology is a life
changer that reduces Nicks and cuts on
your Santa's never never had one problem
with that no oh that's the best in a
business waterproof got the light fuse
the beard trimmer you can really Jam
yourself up if you use you know like
just a regular beard trick unless you
use blade and cream like a real jail get
20 off in free shipping with code
garbage at manscape.com that's 20 off
and free shipping with code garbage and
manscape.com manscape for the perfect
gift that will be this holiday's biggest
hits do it
let me ask you this it's kind of in the
same vein if you were making spaghetti
at your house okay now as an adult yeah
maybe you a couple people whatever uh
maybe us too if we were here this is
your soft invite to having a spaghetti
party so say you got two podcasters over
to make spaghetti I had the spaghetti on
me chunky would you hey we said no fat
jokes would you and you're getting
Jarred sauce okay I don't know if you
make the sauce whatever but in this
reality you make the jar you make the
salt you get a Jarred sauce
would you cook the whole box of pasta
and use the whole jar of sauce or would
you put either of those away
I would probably portion it out I would
put half the pasta in and like half the
sauce because even half is probably more
than almost half of something bro I
didn't even know this every every answer
is half
okay it's good I got I got two more
you're entering your shower I'm entering
my shower entering your shower turn that
you turn the water on yeah right what do
you what do you what are you doing a
door you got a curtain what do you got
there uh I got a sliding glass door okay
this is now this is now and easy does it
go ahead stop leading the witness uh is
the shower head on one of the sides like
the front or the back or is it in the
middle it's on so if I enter the shower
it's to the right
okay so you enter towards the back of
where it's spraying not under it
no yeah yeah that would be what a crazy
person would do I don't even know they
design it that way they yeah could you
get in the front way
I would have to like is that glass slide
as well I would have to contort myself
like with the toilet it would be not
ideal huh
he does that he
sneaking by the toilet no yeah wait what
what's the reasoning here he's I don't
know
um this guy stinks
well if he's complaining that his floor
was so wet for a year and then we
finally got into it and
the controls are up front I get the
water the way I want it and then I step
into the shower you don't come in you
don't come in from the back oh you feel
with the hand and then you go in to make
sure it's all right I enter from okay
here you always do it that way as a kid
I've always done it this way like I will
which way does your dad do it it's the
guy should be talking to that in a
family here this is ridiculous I mean
don't obey the old man's on my side no
way dude there's been like four people
that have been on your side yeah I just
tilt the shower head so it you know it
hits the wall until it heats up yeah so
that I don't get cold when I get in let
it hit the wall for a bit enter from the
back adjust the shower head Primo yeah
all right and then do you put uh uh
you're getting dressed let me get out of
said shower right you entered through
the back and you shower you dry off you
two are really chumming
do you uh you're getting dressed you put
your underwear on uh-huh at what point
do you put your socks on do you put your
pants on then your socks or do you go
underwear socks pants
man
I don't know if I've ever asked my like
I just instinctively do it I've never
retraced my steps and think about like
the way I do it like are you do you
really put your socks on first are you
sitting on the edge of your bed with
your jeans on pudding socks off no I
don't sit to put pants on or sit to put
I do balance okay okay yeah
I do balance as well yeah I like balance
because if I can't do it I feel like
it's a bad sign like we may need to go
to the doctor it's kind of like a
balanced test either way when you're
doing that or do you have pants on or
not you're not when I put socks on uh uh
I think socks go on last
okay this guy's shameful okay here's
here's why uh because if you put socks
on damp feet you want to give your feet
long enough to dry so that the socks go
on smoothly if you're fresh out of the
shower and you put socks on that's a tug
of war I don't need you don't use the
towel to dry between your toes and get
them all dry but still like time is your
friend and what's why am I putting socks
on 10 seconds earlier like what's that
gonna give me you would have to be a
insane person to do that yeah okay
yeah why not just put them on in the
shower at that point
that would be crazy uh
uh see uh someone then mows you 100
bucks yeah right do you do the instant
transfer or do you wait the two to three
business days I never transfer it to my
bank account venmo your venmo balance is
just for you to ping pong between people
uh so you have so you verified your
account one further step I guess because
I can't use my balance anymore I want
they want some sort of information which
I assume is going to screw me somehow so
I haven't given it to him I feel like
venmo is just like ping-ponging twenty
dollars sure if you want your friends
your whole life it's almost like uh
an escrow or something just leave it in
there have a chunk of change that's the
classiest answer I've ever heard that's
pretty good I do I do the instant
transfer myself it's my money and I need
it now do you you know karate
I do not know karate I don't know any
martial arts never had a lesson or
anything like that no can you juggle I
can do three I can do three tennis balls
you're a Juggle in public I've had no
need to
listen I'm gonna shoot this guy unless
you juggle right now comedy has been
going well enough where I haven't had to
Resort all right for my closure somebody
throw me oranges yeah like oh this is
going well does anybody have three
tennis balls that's kind of stuff fruit
will work
um
oh sorry please anybody with web feet in
the family not that I know of okay
anybody with a limp
no what about Hawaiian pizza how do you
feel about that an abomination
what's the name of the place you get a
haircut how much does it cost and what
do you tip Floyd's okay sounds good I
mean that's a chain they're everywhere
oh really it's pretty they have a bunch
of chairs is it like a Hair Cuttery type
thing or like a 50s Greaser like hey
what's up like it's a Super Cuts
basically but they all have tattoos and
[ __ ] it's like corporate cool they're
like hey what's up yeah I got room for
you like we got neckties [ __ ] we're
talking yeah they don't have they don't
have them here no no okay so yeah I'm
sure there's something like it they have
Suavecito and all these products you can
buy they have cool music and it's like
rockabilly kind of are they wearing
those denim uh aprons that like
bartenders and cool chefs right now I
mean they could if they want to if one
is eccentric that way they're very loose
there's no uniform the thing about
Floyd's it's almost like you're lucky to
be there and like they're your friend
and [ __ ] it's a cool spot but I like it
because it's easy to schedule there's a
lot of chairs I don't I don't always go
to the same person sometimes it's
schedule based so I'm like okay Tuesday
at two I'm open I'm getting Frank um or
whoever whoever's available yeah and I
tell them what to do they do it what's
that cost you I think it's I think it's
35 for 38 bucks and then I tip what do
you tip on top of that I'll do a seven
or ten depending on how good it is okay
good yeah and then I do a venmo so that
they don't gotta you know there you go
transferred back yeah uh everywhere
suspenders
never yeah have you had poison ivy as an
adult no when's the last time you were
stung by a bee
a long long time ago I got stung in the
belly button during recess and it was
very painful the hell are you doing out
there I was like I don't know it was
like tall grass and then it went up my
shirt and it stung my belly button and
it hurt it was recess three like
Elementary dude the Everglades
that was on the side of a mountain and
then uh yeah but it's never happened
since have you been stung by bees not in
a long time I keep my head on a swivel
when I'm outside okay stung by a beat as
an adult is pretty trashy yeah that
shouldn't be happening unless you're a
beekeeper that's true yeah well they're
pretty careful too yeah
um
do you call it mini golf or Putt-Putt
mini golf okay
Putt-Putt sounds too like I'm too yeah
I'm too old to say Putt-Putt in a
restaurant what do you do for a water
you do uh tap water you do bottle you do
sparkling
hmm I mean I'm I'm Frugal I'm cheap so
I'll do tap you do tap yeah wrong with
it will you stack the plates at the end
of the meal to help out the server no
okay
uh that to me that's the that's the
right answer
um stacking the plates then I work there
yeah yeah no you should I don't think
you should stack them but if it's a
basket if it comes in a basket yeah you
can stack a basket you stack a nice Fine
China the places I frequent you know
shoes off on the plane no never that's
that's not you shouldn't be allowed to
do that TSA pre-check always clear no
TSA Pre is good enough like clear I just
don't like to cut you off in the past
yeah when there's some clear [ __ ]
oh please wait there uh he's okay yeah
buddy too yeah I just feel like clear is
TSA Pre with a Flavor Flav they just
have a hype man next year who's like
yeah yeah but TSA Pre is the same yeah
yeah I'm a pre-check man myself I didn't
have any pets growing up no we weren't
allowed to have pets no pets no pets wow
goldfish Turtle nothing ah I think I
wanted a dog when I was a kid but then
we couldn't have dogs in the house huh
and then I just didn't care enough to
get a fish or I didn't have that gear
where I'm like I want a guinea pig or I
want a hamster like I just like freedom
bam I'm like uh uh I'm like De Niro in
heat
that's slow me down you know
30 seconds you feel the slipper coming
around the corner away from it 30
minutes or less let's see any plants in
the house now what do you got now you
got an apartment you got your own place
I bought a townhouse
okay go out of town and money haha's
butt there you go any plants in there
I've got a snake plant in the corner
okay and then I have this plant that a
buddy accidentally left there when he
was staying at my place for a few weeks
and I just I keep it on the kitchen
that's a little weird why would he bring
a plant to stay here I don't know and he
he says that it's not his plant like man
you just have a plan you're being
recorded that thing's bugged yeah you
got rooted for my shirt that's what the
feds do they just go like that is that
is that normal
yeah it has like Servo sounds a little
bit that's weird you just have all plant
that your friend says isn't his oh yeah
he's like I don't remember having that
plan your friends taking plants with
them places a little strange yeah isn't
that like Leon the Professional he
always took a plant with him
really you see that movie yeah 100 yeah
I always brought a plant with him
uh do you like egg salad no gross really
is that like a Mayo thing as well do you
like what do you think about Mayo Mayo's
okay if it's just like a very thin coat
on a sandwich I don't want gooped I
don't want I don't want any gooped uh
mayo and also like potato salad not into
it really man
any salads that are not salads I got out
of here I can agree with that coleslaw
get out of here I don't trust this kid
this kid's making a lot of sense any
fireworks in your house right now no I
wish I love them uh have you ever washed
your shoes in a washing machine never I
always think like I should do that
sometime but I can't bring myself to do
to do it I just feel like it's too dirty
and maybe it'll damage the machine oh no
it's the shoes the shoes come out wonky
a bit oh really yeah but interesting but
they smell good and they're clean
they're not getting yelled but they look
like they went through a washing machine
they look a little they come in a little
they look like you got it from Ross yeah
shout out to Ross Dress has the credit
score
um like uh immaculate it is huh yeah so
what are you rocking you got an AMX kind
of cards are we doing Amex I got gold MX
get some miles on it you know Delta man
yes
I pay it off every month you know huh
okay so it's not free money what
Medallion status you had over there you
know I'm not a big Medallion status dude
put a low man on the totem pole says
Cable in it these guys are we all yeah
we're all people what is status what is
medallion
yeah I don't know I just sort of buy
things with a credit card I know that it
goes towards points but I don't I don't
I have buddies who will like fly to New
York just because they want to hit
status they have nothing to do in New
York but they're like I'm gonna lose my
status yeah I don't want to [ __ ] get
on the plane for five hours just for
like status keep that status
just uh I got it from Ross it's uh it's
a Samsonite just a carry-on overhead
thing what color are we talking black
black classic okay it's got It's got
flames on the side
at this point I gotta say sharp kid go
with his money sensible
oh it's a clown house that's the most
practical person corner unit whoa you
don't [ __ ] say that all right I'm not
finding any holes here the Buddy
bringing the plants a little weird
I respect the way he gets in a shower
like sure especially the socks respect
the way he puts his socks on have you
ever eaten at a strip club never would
you would you consider yourself to be
good at laser tag
ah I don't have enough data points I
think I've played it once or twice I'm
some guys are gonna overestimate they're
gonna say they're great like they're
combat veterans or something uh I don't
know what I don't know okay do you know
how to do the Electric Slide or the
Macarena
oh man Macarena probably but it's like
deep in there somewhere electrics lies a
little harder but I know it's like
there's some rocking and then uh it's
kind of like line dancing sure it's like
Urban line dancing any weddings in the
family as of as of recent any family
weddings if you've been to a wedding
I've been causing a friend so mostly I
I've been to Afghan weddings I don't go
to a lot of them like what's going on
there it's more uh festive it's like at
a hotel Ballroom there's dancing uh I
don't know that's a wedding no no
there's no bar no booze because there's
aunties and grandmas and stuff you drink
in the trunk in the parking lot so
there's uncles and young kids and you
pour some like Johnny Walker Black from
the trunk and you have some like Solo
cups so that like it's almost like this
unspoken thing like everyone knows
what's going on but all the men just
drink out of the trunk of cars at this
wedding and then they kind of come in a
little looser and everyone just plays
this game like it's not happening sure
because there can be no alcohol in the
actual wedding okay
all right now you're speaking my
language that's all right
so everyone has to go outside for a
little bit you know sure ever been in a
helicopter uh once I was working at
Boeing and my co-worker wait wait you
worked at Boeing oh yeah I worked at bow
and arrow are you your dad
what's going on here yeah I work there
as an engineer in Long Beach for like
three and a half years okay really yeah
okay that's how I got out to LA I was
doing stand-up for four years we also
didn't ask I'm sorry to cut you out we
didn't ask you where you went to school
after the community oh uh UW University
of Washington okay that's good school
yeah all right graduated and then you
know because stand up like I knew I
wanted to do this since I was 18. so I
knew I had to go to New York or LA and
I'm like I want to keep it West Coast
because my family's in Seattle so I just
applied yeah I just uh applied to jobs
in SoCal so I got a job at Boeing in
Long Beach and then I was drive up as an
engineer yeah yeah pretty good gig I
would assume doing great it's a career
but it was like a stepping stone to me I
I was just using it to get to where you
want to get to today instead of having
to wait tables or whatever you're doing
that yeah exactly having a good salary I
would assume yeah because like no matter
what were you working on Commercial
tooth I was working on the
747-8 freighter and uh you shouldn't
know when he said the [ __ ] planes his
dad was working it was like real
jargonies like the 737-747 what are you
working on what do you design floor
beams so I was part of the floor beams
group
designing the floor beams it was more
like computational so the Design Group
was right next to us and then we would
tell them hey this needs to be wider or
you need to use a stronger Fastener like
it's going to fail at this uh stress you
know would you be in there testing this
[ __ ] out no it was like like there was
no I'm not on the plane no well they do
like the little mini version of the
plane and they put the air over the top
of it well they would have these load
cases in a wireframe and so there's a
software you load up and you get access
to all the different load cases so like
the the stress a plane sees when it
takes off the stress it sees when it has
turbulence the stress the season fully
boards
gonna make those seat belts bigger come
on that was the biggest one we always
did that up top it was the phone with
that if it doesn't if it doesn't pass
the Foley test it doesn't stand a chance
all right I'll give you guys a couple of
hours
you leave the room you're like you guys
done yeah can I come back
uh where was I going with this why was I
talking about engineering I don't know
but it was sounding pretty smart okay
yeah uh you're testing the load beams
specs on the rotary girder all that [ __ ]
yeah
what was what was the question before
the uh no I think we just asked uh you
said you worked yeah I don't even know
how we got there you're smart you're a
smart guy yeah I mean you're a goddamn
[ __ ]
yeah I don't remember I don't remember
anything are you considered an
aeronautical engineer I'm a mechanical
engineer who worked in Aerospace
Aerospace that's pretty good this guy
doesn't even know what [ __ ] Medallion
is what the [ __ ] is the guy building my
planes
I want to at least Diamond okay hmm
wait what were you doing in the
helicopter oh yeah yeah okay okay that's
what it is all right so I was working at
Boeing I was building it yeah what oh
that feels so good yeah yeah so I'm
working there in a cubicle my cubicle
mate over here
he's this older guy maybe in his 40s at
a time I'm like I'm like 23 or so he
he's he flies he flies and he flies
helicopters and he has to get his hours
up to like keep sure the license or
whatever so lunch is coming up he's like
hey I have to fly this helicopter you
want to like you want to ride you want
to go in a helicopter I'm like I'm just
thinking when am I gonna go on a
helicopter again a lunchtime helicopter
this is awesome
I go yeah cool
so we get in the he's like let's take
the doors off so he takes what is it
close to the place because we're right
by Long Beach Airport wait hold on I
missed one thing with this guy is a
pilot too yeah he's an engineer and he's
a pilot it was a helicopter was it a
company helicopter no this is his own
time in order to keep your license
no you aren't taking like the company
yeah he's like take the turret and we're
just going around Long Beach
so yeah it's just a lunchtime helicopter
ride
was it one of those little ones with the
little weird thing that comes up it was
like a smaller helicopter and he's doing
all the stuff and it's a lot of trust
you put in someone like in hindsight
[ __ ] it's weird knowing seafood at lunch
[ __ ] microwaving it get the [ __ ] out
of here you're nuts ever been on a
cruise
uh no and I have no desire to do stand
up like I've been offered like cruise
ship shows I just want to be able to
couple of boat gigs some boat gigs I
want to be able to disappear from the
audience if I choose I don't want to
have to be forced to see these people I
like the option of eating [ __ ] and never
seeing people again
yeah you ever do those shows where after
the gig people are walking out and like
some people are saying oh good job
there's like couple's just like leaving
yeah they give you like a yeah parking
lot this way
um
will you tell the waiter it's someone's
birthday at the table never I like it
even if it is your birthday I don't want
anyone to know yeah yeah yeah yeah it's
pretty good do you own an air fryer I
love I love it I preach the gospel of
air fryer yeah to a problem with air
fryers people that have it it's a
movement it's like Tony Robbins sure
okay yeah do you want to hear my pitches
on airfryer like okay lay it on us on a
reheating level it's already worth the
cost it's a time machine it tastes like
it just came out
Pizza reheating pizza in an air fryer
amazing would you drop on your air fryer
I got a ninja one pretty you know
actually you know what my aunt gave it
to me before air fryers were cool I was
like what is this thing before they were
cool before they were cool she was like
an indie band for like kitchen
appliances she's a hipster yeah so it
just stayed in my bottom cabinet forever
and then I kept on hearing about air
fryers and I go oh [ __ ] I got one I
think I have one of these so I dust it
off oh yeah okay here's the other thing
tots Tots in eight minutes tater tots
tater tots crispy amazing sure I feel
like tots got a bad rap because they're
they were mushy when you were in
elementary school but crispy knots
never had a bad
raps yes they had a mush cold freezer
burn they called a bad rap that would
bother me another thing though is like
tots can switch hit tots are like hash
browns they could be a breakfast potato
of course and they could be a lunch
potato yeah
you can't do fries with eggs
you could do tarts with eggs no you
could definitely do fries fries with
eggs
screw balls fries with eggs not in the
morning it's my favorite breakfast
substitution
give me the fries baby
I mean you can do it walk out of here
you can do it technically I guess I feel
like I'm like a dirt bag uh Gordon
Ramsay like fries with eggs
tots with eggs uh no well in New York a
lot if the diner you go to the diners at
night and you get if you are getting
breakfast to go we're out of hash browns
we can do fries oh so that would be the
potato but that video I'm talking two
three o'clock in the morning yeah you're
all [ __ ] up right it doesn't matter I
think I think a french fries in the
morning is a wild thank you Choice okay
it is yes deep fried food in the morning
like that
I would never do that to my body do you
have tater tots in your house right now
yes I have like two bags I have reserved
hearts in case I run back up
tops fail that's a real engineer
there you go redundancy we have a code
red oh wait I have backup time nevermind
we're good
um uh what kind of what kind of brand
you banging with on the tots okay there
is it Oneida is that one or Ida or ryda
Oregon Idaho or Ida that's everywhere
that's pretty standard but there's this
tater tot from Gelson's that you can get
that is it's an Idaho Potato I forget
what the brand is but it's the tater
tots from Gelson's that are
like above and beyond any thoughts I've
had top shelf yeah top shelf thoughts
top shelf thoughts
okay all right
um
I mean here's the deal I'm pretty good
here I think you have a globe in your
house
like a like a world globe yeah like a
globe
no okay is that common no yeah that's
true yeah no Globe huh what kind of what
are you whipping around in L.A what are
you driving I upgraded I have an Audi A5
okay okay
but before I was driving a 2007 Mazda 3
still pretty nice that's for a very long
time stick shift I also when I was
living in Austin for a few months during
the pandemic I shipped the Mazda
to Austin so I could drive so I could
have a car out there what color is the
Audi White
so white Audi it's a white out that's
clean it's like a dentist's car yeah
that's what I was going for it's got
real pediatrician Vibes my cards say DDS
my brother's a dentist actually your
brother's a dentist
[Laughter]
um you working out uh yeah less so than
I used to maybe like two times a week or
three times your membership LA Fitness
yeah okay
that's pretty good how many suits do you
own like two two I might buy another one
I'm trying to buy I want to get like a
nice one because before I would just buy
a Zara suit and then that's even the
high end of it really suits no I'm an h
m man myself H M's nice too but Tsar is
better slightly slightly and then I
would tailor the Zara suit but I kind of
want to get a grown man suit yeah you
know do you have anything just one yeah
I just did it you have an IRA or
anything like that set up yeah you do
yeah yeah yeah
401K from Boeing I assume I transferred
it because I don't work there anymore so
I transferred it to some like other type
of Fidelity 401K and I contribute the
maximum every year and yeah I mean
listen the kid's classy yeah Throw Down
the Line
fantastic yeah Top Notch runs a tight
shift High ship man I mean I thought
early on what deodorant to use I use Arm
and Hammer no aluminum the L I'm
surprised I didn't say aluminum aluminum
no yeah that's good stuff
it's not gonna um there's no
antiperspirant quality to it that's the
only downside but then I just hear about
all the aluminum stuff and I'm like yeah
as long as I smell fine that's fine
what's a toothpaste well I do whatever's
on sale whether it's a Colgate there's
so many varieties they have sparkles in
them they have fluoride they're jumping
Brands
can you taste the difference between a
Colgate and a Crest sure yeah really
yeah it just tastes like minty [ __ ] in
my mouth I know centadine tastes too
weird so I won't do that first was like
dessert when I was a kid get my hands on
one of those like after dinner you like
one tube of crust I think there's an
experiment and I thought it was like
sweeter
um
I can't tell the difference so I just
buy whatever is cheapest but it's
usually a Colgate or a Crest they have a
basket of them and it'll be like I do
agree colgating a Crest are relatively
interchangeable if you're not going you
know something super specific are you
cooking at the house are you eating out
there that's that's my problem my I eat
out that's probably my one Vice like
eating out too much
or eating out nothing okay
I'll order in a lot you know well here's
the thing when it comes to cooking I'll
do a breakfast that's an easy meal to
bang out eggs that's super easy eggs
tots
these kind of goddamn tots yeah I love
tots you need a potato never fries and
then uh
yeah and if I cook like a steak I can do
that's pretty easy I like just grilling
a piece of meat and having a side you
got a grill uh
no I'll do I'll do like a skillet like a
cast iron skillet
I don't whip you up a nice then
yeah I mean I don't know what to
hey kids class throw it through sharp
kid good family educated Brothers a
dentist drives a nice car got a 401 got
Ira money put away
the only the trashiest thing about them
is that currently is the air fryer love
which I'll give it but you know but I
mean I feel like the air fryer Bridges
all economic classes like everyone is
all about that these days yeah you can
get them on the air fryer because that's
what I'm just saying it's not class it's
not the classiest thing that's a time
thing you know like it's a time and
flavor thing that even
rich people are also they're not having
a stat not known as status can you speak
a second language a little bit of Farsi
not as good as I should
you understand it though I understand
more than I can speak okay
that's pretty good yeah I mean dude I
thought the haircut's in the bathroom I
thought for yeah we were going in the
right direction I thought we I thought
we had them [ __ ] Soup To Nuts that
was the last [ __ ] tragedy thing he
said and his mom was about to become an
entrepreneur so I mean shut down
Hawaiian pizza pretty hard too
um
do you eat over the sink
uh
no yeah anybody in your family ever
claim to see a UFO no you keep your
batteries in the refrigerator no why is
that a thing yeah it's a trashy man
they have hand towels
uh like a towel on the railing in a
bathroom right yeah what else would you
do just like dry your hands off with
your shower towel no that's crazy you
use your wipes damn this kid's you might
be the classiest dude that ever roll up
everybody 100 percent the nuts grade A
Class holy [ __ ] wow very few have come
in and beat the glunk golf yeah damn
yeah part of they wanted to be trash
though I thought I had some trashy no
[ __ ] worked at Boeing what are you
talking about whipping and ALDI they
asked about laser tag you said data
points yeah that's true that's a good
thing yeah
you use a couple of real smart guy
terminology that I didn't understand I
took it as a fence
do you think later down the line I can
get like an honorary trash degree that'd
be great yeah yeah like Cosby come do
commencement yeah yeah
buddy what a [ __ ] good time gang
special at right now hat trick you gotta
check it out it's on the YouTube page
what else you got coming up brother let
him know just on tour so I think I'm
coming back to New York in April I'll be
playing Bell house
and just go to female.com for other tour
dates great and then subscribe to the
YouTube channel there's a bunch of [ __ ]
coming out and the specials there yeah
buddy yeah check out the special
everybody what a good time we love you
this was so much fun KP what do you got
for him uh like I said The Gramercy
theater get those [ __ ] tickets let's
sell the [ __ ] out baby big time I bet
the whole bet the whole house on this
place no one shows up I'm broke Grammer
sees huge awesome that's so cool thank
you and then obviously patreon the whole
nine yards we'll see on the road we're
announcing our new 2023 tour coming up
uh soon gang we love you we'll see you
next week